mr. president thank you we would like to
know what kind of president you will be
now that the job is yours officially
let's use world leaders as a comparison
is there a president a prime minister or
perhaps another head of state whom you
admire whom you consider an example to
follow well uh Brazil you think was well
in Brazil all I have as example our
former president Joe Cellino Kubasaki he
was a very active president very Pro
modernity in terms of the Brazilian
agenda and also a happy it was a happy
administration my role as you know I
will only have two years and four months
in government and so my role will
consists in putting Brazil back in track
that's all I want
we assumed or took office at a time
where the country was in a very poor and
significantly bad economic situation we
want to of course increasingly improve
the deficit and generate job
opportunities and growth for the nation
mr. president you want to cap spending
government spending in real terms as
well as make social security call it
more restrictive these are two ambitious
proposals that both require
constitutional change and they are not
without opposition so let us talk about
timing a timeline if you will
realistically when will these two
important reforms be passed into law I
suppose the fuses are equal these are
two difficult reforms I acknowledge that
but they are essential and precisely
because they are essential I believe
that we will pass these issues or
subject matters in Congress and the time
required more precisely regarding
measures to cap government spending as
you know we were setting a ceiling to
government spending that may be renewed
in every budget year based on the
previous year's inflation so in that
regard I am absolutely certain that we
will be able to pass that measure before
the end of this year the other reform is
the
Social Security Social Security slash
pension reform which will be submitted
to Congress this year but we'll
certainly be passed next year first half
of next year next year that is more or
less than the timeline that is required
for these two bills to be passed if I
may I'd like to refer to a yet another
reform a third reform labor reform to
ensure jobs are available a matter that
has actually been addressed by the
Brazilian Supreme Court and several of
the proposals I have put forth so far
one of them actually is about ensuring
prevalence of collective agreements
established between workers and
employers based on the provisions of the
law the Federal Supreme Court has
already made a decision or issued a
ruling in that regards so again these
are issues that are absolutely essential
these measures are absolutely essential
and there's a great degree of
understanding on the part of both the
Brazilian Congress and also the
Brazilian people at large about those
needs essential but as you acknowledge
difficult so I would like to know what
compromises allowances if you will are
you prepared to make to ensure that the
budget bill or the spending bill gets
passed this year as you say and that the
Social Security reform bill will be
passed next year yeah we have a
timetable and I'm going to talk about it
with great peace of mind I mean the
timeline we have regarding government
spending or the ceiling to government
spending the target date is October the
third or the a things that the latest
part of the work of a special committee
in the lower house of parliament and
only later before the end of the year
will do matter before worded to a
plenary session in the lower house of
parliament for approval before the end
of October November and then it will be
sent on to Congress and the Senate and
Senate will have about one and a half
months to pass the bill so I believe
that the current outlook end of it is
that no later than December 15th or 18th
we should have passed the ceiling the
government spent
and again regarding pension reform we're
going to submit it to Congress this year
it involves a proposed constitutional
amendment as you yourself indicated so
yes
it does require the proper procedures be
followed in Congress which may take more
time but before the end of the year we
will certainly have covered those
measures the reason I ask about
compromises is because many Brazilians
say the government isn't spending enough
on education the government isn't
spending enough on health care and if
you camp spending that means unless you
take it from somewhere else you won't be
able to spend more on health care and
you won't be able to spend more on
schools my stoma jugamos Sao opposition
Eastin yeah but that is a in argument
very often used by the opposition
because if you read the contents of the
bill you will see that the nature is of
an overall nature in other words the
ceiling is of an overall nature there's
an overall ceiling to all government
spending without any reduction in
education and health care for instance
for the budget the 2017 budget we have
already applied the ceiling as if to the
proposed constitutional amendment had
already being passed and unlike what is
said we have increased the budget
appropriations for health and education
these two sectors will not at all be
somehow harmed by the constitutional
ceiling mr. president how long is it
going to take to close the budget
deficit how many years because I think
it has to be years before Brazil has a
primary surplus FF a janazah but yet was
revealed on deficits that's true we took
office and we found the deficit to half
of 270 billion Brazilian reals and 500
million we have already established
measures to reduce the deficit to 130
billion Brazil our house and I believe
that in 2018 we will still have to live
with a small deficit but all of that of
course is the result of fiscal and
economic policy aimed at lowering
inflation there is also a trend that we
will reach the center of the inflation
target which is about four or four point
five percent for next year and
I said before we also want to of course
create many jobs and I confirm what you
just stated yes it will be two three
years perhaps before we totally
eliminate the deficit I agree but I must
say that some time ago not too long ago
I got this very telling and research
finding indicating that if we had set
this spending ceiling four years ago by
this time we would have no deficit
whatsoever in Brazil anymore mr.
president the support you relied on for
gentleman's impeachment in Congress is
fragile let's say the Brazilian people
themselves aren't in love with the idea
of austerity how do you maintain the
momentum for the bold reforms that
you've announced over the past four
months during your term as interim
president the very same reforms domestic
businesspeople and foreign investors are
counting on to revive the economy how do
you maintain that momentum yeah yeah why
do you look at I have or say this again
well first first of all you put it very
well during our interim period in office
we took a number of different measures
one of which was of course to send
Congress a proposal governing a ceiling
to government spending a second measure
we took was to do with the
public-private partnerships we have just
recently launched the broad program and
I'm now in New York and while in New
York I will be talking about us-based
the investors the day after tomorrow
with a view to ensuring more foreign
investments flow into Brazil of course
very much in line and the in tandem with
domestic investments where and whenever
possible now with these reasons
announcements we are opening up for
public concessions about 34 different
lines of business including ports
airports railways oil and gas industry
opportunities etc so we are totally
changing the business climate in the
country furthermore may I state for the
record that there has been a tremendous
resumption of
of confidence or trust first we were
able to reestablish hope and now we're
managing to successfully re-establish
trust which will of course trigger not
only a inflow of more investments of
course there's some degree of resistance
to innovation at times it all depends to
a certain extent on the way we are able
to communicate or the way we are able to
properly explain the proposed reforms
and at this point in time we already see
Brazilians the Brazilian population
beginning to understand that these
reforms are absolutely key and essential
to recover resume hope and trust in the
country mr. president let's talk about
operation car wash lavage Otto the
investigation into corruption in and
around Petrobras is it a simple matter
of black and white the more corruption
the investigation exposes the better or
is it more shaded more complex if you
will is there a point at which the
investigation becomes counterproductive
maybe even destabilizing versus a
tequila
I'll give you zero on this about that
you know that there is some division
around his issues some people seem to
think there has been some exaggeration
but those of us who are in the executive
we do not at all Merrill with it
especially the judiciary nor do we
interfere with matters that are
addressed in Brazil by the federal
public prosecutor's office and by
federal just judges there is no
interference whatsoever on the part of
the executive in these matters and that
is precisely what provides institutional
stability in Brazil as has by extension
being likewise the case during the
impeachment process of the previous
administration it was a process that was
regularly conducted by the legislative
with proper monitoring and follow-up by
the judiciary so yes institutions in
Brazil are working very well and
properly the car wash operation the car
wash investigation for example will
continue until such time as all illegal
actions may have been looked into it
even if it continues to expose
allegations of corruption within your
own party at the highest levels
same-same problema yes no problem
whatsoever because what has happened in
fact you used a very important or
appropriate phrase they have been
allegations only what does that mean
well someone may enter into a
testimonial plea bargaining agreement
and refers to one or two politicians so
a regular process is fully underway so
that means that you have first of all of
course an investigation following an
inquiry and then of course you have an
indictment followed by a discussion in
the judiciary before a sentence is
issued so Brazil will face up to this a
question very much within peace of mind
mr. president I would like to know how
far you're willing to go to end
corruption in Brazil would you end
immunity from prosecution for lawmakers
and senior government officials refused
mo0 sake you know we have done that
already very recently I sanctioned a
bill of law providing for say a greater
sense of morality if you understand the
in appointment of persons to hold key
positions such as directors in
state-owned corporations for example
which does not mean that the political
class cannot possibly appoint persons
but the fact is they cannot possibly
appoint political people but only
technical experts people who have some
experience and exposure in addressing
the matters that are part of the agenda
of that given state-owned cooperation of
public entity so this has been
established for good as a result of my
sanctioning a recent bill of law while
in office as an interim president but
does that address the question of
immunity from prosecution for elected
representatives for lawmakers yes Dada
Muni Taj lemon the question of say
congressional or parliamentarian
immunity that is something we will not
change because immunity by virtue of
reasons opinions and votes has been a
traditional form of immunity in the
Brazilian law domestically as has always
been the case here in the US in the
United States now as regards the
potential for
a criminal action being perpetrated of
course not even members of Congress are
at all protected from any criminal
procedures and actually this kind of
procedure isn't the way in Brazil in
many cases mr. president I thank you
very much for your time ok thank you my
pleasure thank you